all we say to america is be true to what
you said on paper
if i lived in
china or even russia or any totalitarian
country
maybe i could understand
some of these illegal injunctions
maybe i could understand the denial of
certain basic first amendment privileges
because they haven't committed
themselves to that
over there
but somewhere i read
of the freedom of assembly
somewhere i read
of the freedom of speech somewhere i
read
of the freedom oppressed
somewhere i read
that the greatness of america is the
right to protest far right
[Applause]
hello internet i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report it is july 6 20 22 and
that of course was dr martin luther king
jr who used to be considered a pretty
cool cat he was always fighting for
equality not equity and
trying to push us
to further believe in the aspirational
documents that are our founding
documents what's in that paper right
there the defense of freedom of assembly
and of speech etc etc and that those
things are not guaranteed all over the
world but they are
guaranteed here and unfortunately we
seem to be giving them away and that is
going to be much of the theme of the
show today uh as you guys know i am
banned on the twitter uh 1.3 million
followers an awful lot of wasted time on
there i am banned uh we're going to get
to why i was banned jordan peterson is
banned and i sense more people are about
to be banned and
free speech
whether it is
now through our technological overlords
who are crushing down on it or the
government
it's hanging on by a thread ladies and
gentlemen it is hanging on by a thread
let me remind you guys real quick if you
want to see me live where they cannot
censor me where no one can press a
button and shut me down uh july 14th at
the miami improv i will be on stage
doing a live reuben report episode this
is going to be a completely different
situation than any of the other tour
stops we're going to have all sorts of
clips we're going to go through with you
guys audience q a it's going to be it's
going to be fun and different you can go
to miami improv.com
by the way we had 100 vip tickets that
we were selling they all sold out
immediately we have just in the last few
moments michael i'm confirmed i can say
it we have just in the last few moments
opened up 40 more that gets you the vip
option where if you want it you get the
one second hug out of me pretty good
anyway we're gonna be talking about
defending american values today
something that i'm into and uh need a
little defense before we get to that let
me talk about super beats you know if
you've been watching the show for the
past few months i've been telling you
about how super beats heart choose give
me the energy i need no matter how crazy
my schedule gets look how energetic i am
right now well here's another super
beats customer review backing me up
didn't wait as long as i did to try
super beats heart shoes they are
delicious with no weird aftertaste a
convenient way to take a healthy
supplement i was skeptical but am now a
believer see for yourself try them
introducing a new way to start your day
super beets heart chews a tasty treat
that'll give you the energy you need and
are good for you no more afternoon
coffees energy drinks and candy for a
quick pick-me-up add two delicious
plant-based super beets heart chews to
your morning routine and promote
heart-healthy energy for your day
without a caffeine crash because super
beets heart chews unique clinically
researched grape seed extract promotes
heart healthy energy and normal blood
pressure as part of a healthy lifestyle
i choose super beat heart shoes for
heart healthy energy and you should too
the grape seed extract used in super
beat heart chews has been clinically
shown to be two times as effective as at
supporting normal blood pressure as a
healthy lifestyle alone do more for your
heart and treat yourself with super
beats heart choose to make it easy to
get started you can get up to 45 percent
off plus free shipping at superbeats.com
reuben hurry it's their best offer
available anywhere that's superbeats.com
reuben for up to 45 off superbeats.com
ruben and now back to me okay
so we have to talk about
this twitter thing and i want to be
clear about this uh as i discussed with
my guys this morning i don't really want
to make this about me i really don't uh
i wish that i was sort of reporting on
or talking about the things that were
happening in the world and they had
nothing to do with me other than i'm
someone that talks about them right
but i am in the thick of this thing i'm
in the middle of the muck uh in that i
was banned on twitter
for talking about the fact that jordan
peterson was banned on twitter and
whether you like twitter or not whether
you are on twitter or not it is the
global pr service it is the place where
the tastemakers where the people who are
the mass influencers how it is the place
that that they go to to spread
information it has become the new public
square that may be very very dangerous
for america that may be very very
dangerous for the world it may be a
horrible thing and yes we need to build
new pipes and all of those things but at
the moment it is the reality that that
is the place that sort of drives
everything else that goes on online and
then as you guys know the things that go
on online then leak out into the real
world so the daily wire covered me
getting the boot so let's uh jump over
to them host dave rubin was suspended
from twitter on tuesday morning for a
tweet announcing best-selling author and
clinical psychologist jordan peterson
had been suspended for tweeting about
ellen page an actress who now identifies
as a man named elliot
the insanity continues at twitter jordan
peterson has been suspended for this
tweet about ellen page reuben tweeted
wednesday captioning a screenshot of
peterson's post he just told me he will
quote never delete the tweet
i have been suspended by twitter for
posting a screenshot of jordan
peterson's tweet which got he himself
suspended rubin said in a statement
reported by shapiro while it is unclear
how i broke their terms of service it is
clear that they are breaking their
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders by letting a bunch of woke
activists run the company the reuben
report host continued i hope elon musk's
purchase of twitter goes through so he
can blow up their servers and humanity
can move past the pervasive twisted
self-imposed mental institution he said
billionaire elon musk's bid for twitter
has been accepted by the platforms board
in the meantime you can find me at
rubinreport.locals.com the platform i
created to fight big tech censorship
something we need now more than ever the
host added peterson was suspended from
twitter over a tweet he posted on june
22nd about paige remember when pride was
a sin and ellen page just had her
breasts removed by a criminal
physician he wrote okay so you guys get
it
now let me just
sort of put one part of this in a box at
some level it does not really matter
what jordan said or what i said the
simple fact is obviously obviously we
were not breaking any law and we were
not directing any hate towards any one
person or any one group of people based
on anything including trans people
jordan is allowed as a clinical
psychologist as the world's leading
public intellectual and i truly mean
that the world's leading public
intellectual he is allowed
and encouraged and i would say we need
it to have opinions and they might be
controversial opinions on the hot button
issues of the day and that a group of
people
of increasing numbers generally young
women are now
literally castrating themselves uh
chopping off their breasts and
transitioning to be men although they
obviously are not biological men that'll
probably get me kicked off youtube now
too
that is happening right now and of
course people that are public people who
talk about these things who get into
these fights should be addressing these
issues of course they should be
addressing these issues now i could talk
about this all day long but i don't
think i can do it any better than jordan
peterson and he addressed his suspension
in an absolutely fiery
just perfect response he posted on his
youtube channel here's about 35 seconds
of it i'm not taking down that tweet or
acknowledging that my tweet violated the
twitter rules
up yours woke moralists
we'll see who cancels who
twitter's a rat hole in the final
analysis and i have probably contributed
to that while trying to use understand
and master that horrible toxic platform
no doubt i owe some apologies for that
and i'm trying to learn but it's a
relief in some real sense to be banned
and i regard it under the present
conditions as a badge of honor
wow
i mean
i can't beat that i honestly can't beat
that and i would encourage you to watch
the the full
video that jordan posted there
you know it's so interesting because he
acknowledges that he himself and i would
acknowledge the same for myself
are we our best selves on twitter have
we all contributed to whatever the hell
it is that we all know is going on right
now this slow descent to hell that we're
all in of course we've all contributed
it
to it right we've all been part of it
all right unless you're not on twitter
in which god bless you you're living
your best life um but we've all been
part of it he also mentions that it's a
relief in some respects to be banned on
twitter and i do have to tell you in the
you know over 24 hours that i have been
banned i have to say it has been a bit
of a relief instead of in any free
moment that i have my hand just go into
my pocket know what's going on on
twitter what's going on what's happening
um there's a relief there but the
broader point that jordan is addressing
is he is he is standing up for a
principle
and it is i would argue the same
principle that dr martin luther king jr
was talking about in that cold open that
we showed you that the principle of free
speech your ability to say what you
think without being pushed to the
margins of society as long as you're not
breaking the laws what did what did
martin luther king say in that called
open i want this thing to be what's on
the paper what's on the paper if it
wasn't on the paper the defense of free
speech if the first amendment wasn't
there and the right to assemble and
share your thoughts and protest if it
all wasn't on the papers maybe we'd be
having a complete other conversation but
in this country
this 246 year old country it's on the
paper that you can share your thoughts
so jordan has drawn the line in the sand
jordan reiterated to me yesterday that
he is not going to delete that tweet and
he will not come back on twitter
i will in full transparency tell you
that i did delete the tweet now it was
not because i was acknowledging that i
did anything wrong i deleted the tweet
because twitter said that if i delete
the tweet i would have access to my
direct messages these are the personal
messages that i can send people now i
have no doubt that the woke whack jobs
at twitter are reading my direct
messages and reading everyone else
direct messages too uh i wanted access
to those direct messages so i could get
word out that i had been suspended and
thus uh that's exactly what happened
yesterday and ellen page was the number
one trend on twitter most of the day
with my name uh ellen and then of course
twitter issued a statement that they
shouldn't have allowed ellen page
name to trend because that's dead naming
her i mean the whole thing is so stupid
the whole thing is so profoundly stupid
everything by the way that the woke
touch becomes profoundly stupid uh so
okay so i want to link this to more
broadly what's happening in the country
so we will get there i promise you uh
just i want to point out a couple people
who uh offered some defense and some
insight into what's going on ben shapiro
posted this on instagram i thought this
was interesting perhaps this is
twitter's chain strategy for banning if
you note that twitter has suspended
someone for mentioning the unmentionable
they erase you then someone else
mentions that you have been suspended
and they are purged as well
dead naming is when you notice that
someone has changed his or her name
gender ideology violates the laws of
biology and logic as well as physics now
we must engage in time travel and
pretend that there was a man named
elliot page who starred in juno as a
pregnant girl so ben of course is
bringing up a couple great points here
first off just addressing anyone else's
suspension this causes the twitter
inception of banning and suspension
they'll just keep banning everybody ben
did not get banned and we uh we were
sort of wondering why didn't ben get
banned for addressing me getting banned
because of jordan getting banned and
it's like i do think one of the things
that they do there you have to remember
these are a bunch of woke activists
running this country and where is elon
musk in all of this i'm not quite sure
we'll get to him in just a second but i
do think they have to what they're doing
is they're playing a little bit of
whack-a-mole here and they know they
can't just blow up the game at once so
it's like you can't take jordan out one
day meet a couple days later and ben a
couple days later you have to spread
these things out because people start
forgetting about people right that's
part of the problem here that's why i've
posed the question to my locals
community this morning like should i get
back on twitter and fight should i take
the fight to them should i use my time
on twitter to expose the nonsense mock
them in all of those things which is
what i try to do here on a daily basis
and really call out the nonsense or do i
just pack up and go
you know do you abdicate the throne do
you go hey i did what i could do here
i'm not interested in this and i want to
build new things i mean you know my
feelings about building new things it's
why i created locals it's why we merged
with rumble it's why i'm working on a
couple other projects as well and it's
like i'm very interested in that i saw
some incredible comments on local so
thank you guys who are playing along uh
arguing both ways that you go in you go
into the rat's nest and you fight that's
one way of doing it that you walk and
you let them you know implode and you
let them just go on that endless descent
and you go and you go to greener
pastures i think there's great arguments
on both sides i haven't decided what i'm
gonna do yet uh but ted cruz senator ted
cruz who is a good one on the short list
of sane politicians uh he defended me
last night which i appreciate uh this is
insane free speech terrifies leftist
nitwits free dave rubin free jordan
peterson of course dan bongino who is
just uh bongino is just blowing up i
mean he really is just blowing up the
twitter communists have come for another
guilty of wrong think uh and then i've
got a couple things from douglas murray
here because he addresses this in just
such a brilliant way uh so one of these
i think i showed you yesterday so reuben
report has been suspended from twitter
for commenting on jordan b peterson
being suspended from twitter does
twitter intend to have a future also
could it explain whether elliott was
ever ellen or caitlyn was ever bruce so
now douglas cause you just do it so
freaking well uh here's another thing
that douglas posted and then there's a
video clip we're going to show you
douglas wrote yesterday can twitter
confirm what the name of this oh so
insightful interviewee is slash was did
this interview happen if so what was the
name of the interviewee now what i am
about to show you what douglas murray
linked to right there i'm going to try
to tell you facts at the time and this
is only about a year and a half ago or
so this was during the uh jessie
smallette thing
uh a woman by the name of ellen page
went on a late night talk show to talk
about jesse smallette
the horrible racist incident how evil
america is how bad the rest of us are
that's what happened but don't take my
word for it here it is the media that's
saying it's a debate whether or not
which has happened to jesse small it is
a hate crime it's absurd
this
[Applause]
the president and the vice president
mike pence who like wishes i couldn't be
married let's just be clear
the vice president of america wishes i
didn't have the love with my wife
he wanted to ban that in indiana
okay so everything she that was ellen
page at the time don't come get me evil
tech overlords at the time that was
ellen page stephen colbert there who is
a total tool and of course agreeing with
her as she lies the jessie smilething
was a total hoax there was no racist
incident he concocted it himself he was
convicted of that remember so she goes
on a late night talk show she ellen page
she was a woman
she goes on this late night talk show
she completely lies about what had
happened a whole bunch of us knew it was
a lie from beat one beat one by the way
aoc put out tweets saying it wasn't a
hoax and that it was real and approved
systemic racism um hillary clinton did
you know all the usual suspects kamala
harris blah blah blah
all of these people do those things
nancy pelosi etc okay you get all that
well there she is spreading
misinformation now that clip is allowed
to be online a woman spreading
misinformation ellen page spreading
misinformation she's allowed to do that
so that gets out there uh then this clip
we found this clip yesterday jack
vasobic found this one this is an
interesting clip somehow a brazilian
president uh bolsonaro sat down with
ellen page not too long ago ellen page
not too long ago ellen page not too long
ago
i'm gay
so do you think that i should have been
beaten as a child
to not be gay now
i'm not going to look at you and say i
think you're gay that doesn't matter to
me you're very nice if i were a cadet in
the military academy and saw you on the
street i would whistle at you all right
you're very pretty
first off she doesn't seem very nice i
don't know what boldness
and aldesaro i don't know what he's
saying there that she seems very nice um
but but you see what he says he says
you're very pretty right and obviously
he wasn't going to beat her he doesn't
care but these woke people ellen page
from that video what they want is
endless victimhood what ellen page who
was on the stephen colbert [ __ ]
comedy hour wants is to be viewed as a
victim and she wants to point to events
that are completely fabricated to show
you how evil america is and all of those
things that's and i don't even mean to
make this about ellen page i don't i
literally do not care about ellen page
as i said yesterday i kind of like those
x-men movies x-men it's kind of funny
x-men ellen page the whole thing there
um
but
um
i don't mean to make this about ellen
page this is more broadly what is
happening as these people who lie about
everything who spread misinformation
they somehow have the levers of power
when it comes to tech companies to say
you cannot call some like what are you
supposed to say are you supposed to say
i think you're supposed to say the
artist formerly known as ellen page now
known as elliott page played a certain
character in x-men we should not
do this
they they are never going to stop if you
think that this if you all thought it
was crazy five years ago when a bunch of
us were calling out the beginnings of
this and a bunch of us were by the way
it has all got uh consistently worse and
it will get consistently worse how do i
know it because the media right now the
corporate press
not only
are they uh
lying about everything right so they put
out the jesse smallett lies they put out
the very fine people on both sides lies
they put out the brett kavanaugh is a
serial rapist they put all those things
out but they're telling you they want to
make sure that you're censored here is
soon to be unemployed cnn host brian
stelter talking about how we've got to
censor people
there is up in the sky information
pollution
and the polluters
are trying to deflect blame
dishonest cries of censorship are
filling fox's airwaves with charges that
these guys right here are being
suppressed
the word censorship's been invoked
almost 400 times on fox this month alone
and more than 300 times on newsmax most
people
want clean air and blue skies and
accurate news and rational views and
then in that healthy environment that
looks beautiful
then we can have great fights about
taxes and regulation and healthcare and
all the rest the vast majority of people
can agree that disinformation about
let's say the pandemic is unhealthy it's
harmful so how can that harm be reduced
well big tech platforms say they are
removing lies about vaccines and
stamping out stop the steel bs and
queueing on content
now do these private companies have too
much power sure many people would say
yes of course they do but reducing a
liar's reach is not the same as
censoring freedom of speech freedom of
speech is different than freedom of
reach
and algorithmic reach is part of the
problem
freedom of speech is different than
freedom of reach me oh he's such a tool
that guy uh it's so interesting because
he's talking about disinformation about
vaccines and it's like he and the entire
machine that he supports was the prime
purveyor of disinformation about
vaccines if you get the vaccine you're
not going to get coveted you're not
going to transmit covert oh that was the
president of the united states joe biden
right just about a year ago that was
june of uh 2021. these are the people
who lie about absolutely everything
stelter is one of the people who tweeted
about and repeatedly on his show said
that jesse smallett was the victim of a
lynching it turned out to be a lie so
when they're telling you oh those guys
are worried about censorship so we
should decrease their reach he's
signaling
he's signaling to the tech companies
what can you do can you make sure that
people get shadow banned can you make
sure that people when they click on like
click like on something the like doesn't
actually appear or maybe it doesn't get
amplified to their uh to their feeds or
whatever we don't even know right what
do i always say it's not that what i
know that they're doing that i'm worried
about it's all the [ __ ] that i don't
know that i that they're doing that i'm
worried about um so the point is they do
not truly care about decency in the
public square they do not truly care
about honestly having a conversation or
defending free speech or any of those
things they pretend to while they are
the ones who purvey
all of the noxious views that are
destroying the country right now
lori lightfoot ladies and gentlemen
the toxicity
in our public discourse
is a thing that i think we should all be
concerned about right and it's ironic
obviously that we're having this
conversation and what happened
on independence day you know we're not
like a lot of other countries where the
independence their version of
independence day is marked with you know
troops and tanks and no what we do in
the united states is we come together as
a community
[Applause]
you see what they do this is what they
do and only one of those videos will be
shown on mainstream media the uh the
npcs the non-playable characters the
blue and on people the people who
believe in cnn and msnbc and who believe
the mainstream they only see one of
those oh there's lori lightfoot and
she's talking about how we're such a
decent good country and my god lori
lightfoot must be pretty darn good
they're not going to show oh the [ __ ]
clarence thomas
part of lori lightfoot they're also not
going to show this remember this one a
couple weeks ago from lori lightfoot to
my friends in the lgbtq plus community
the supreme court is coming for us next
this moment has to be a call to arms
yeah that seems like a call to violence
a call to arms technically that's a call
to violence but when you're a democrat
you're allowed to do it because there is
something called democrat privilege that
is the only real privilege in the united
states when you're a democrat you're
allowed to get away with everything she
happens to be a black lesbian democrat
which puts you at the top of the
freaking thing
uh by the way how's lori lightfoot doing
over in chicago well uh 54 people
were shot on july 4th weekend uh in her
city so she talks a good game you know
she really cares really cares about
america she really cares about her city
people are being shot uh obviously left
and right there was the highland park
shooting uh over the weekend obviously
as well i'm not going to get into the
specifics about the shooter or any of
that stuff but i want to show you uh i'm
going to draw a straight line here and
you'll see why i just said that phrase
in a moment i want to draw a straight
line from the way these people talk to
what actually happens so eric swalwell
you guys know eric swallow he's a
congressman in california he is a
complete fraud he's a vapid nothing he
100
for sure was sleeping with a chinese spy
this is known by everybody in the
intelligence community um it is
absolutely known i am not making it up
google it for yourself if you don't
believe me uh eric swalwell tweeted this
yesterday and i thought this was
interesting now this is in reference
to the shooting that happened in
highland park he takes a picture of
lauren bobert who i've had on the show
who i think is a good decent woman and
certainly a patriot i have some
political disagreements with her that's
fine but she is a legal law-abiding
citizen who owns a gun and she takes a
picture of her and then he takes a
picture of the guy who did the shooting
in highland park let's start drawing
straight lines now lauren bobert has
nothing to do with that shooting that
shooting probably has far more to do
with lori lightfoot if we're being
honest i mean she's the mayor of chicago
right um
this happened in illinois uh where we
know people are being killed left and
right all the time but this is what they
do they take it so right now if we were
to play by their rules if we were to
play by their rules if some crazy
leftist and they're an awful lot of
crazy leftists out there if some crazy
leftist was to shoot lauren bobert right
now would that be the fault of eric
swalwell
right i mean he just linked lauren
bobert to a murderer so if someone
wanted to do a little vigilante justice
would we be able to blame eric uh eric
swalwell for that
do you see what this game is like what
they're actually doing here and the more
that we play the game with them and i
think this is the part that i'm going to
have to try to figure out as i continue
to do this show the problem is if we
just
keep responding to them if we just keep
oh this person got banned that person
got banned oh they said this then we'll
just constantly be following them right
we're going to constantly be following
the white rabbit but when you follow the
white rabbit the hope is you're going to
find something true at the end this is a
white rabbit where you're going to find
nothing true because there is nothing
true in what they are doing
and the simple fact is that everything
that jordan peterson said in that tweet
was true
uh everything that i said i mean all i
did was basically say he shouldn't have
been banned for this was true and it's
not just about what happens on twitter
it is the simple fact that they are
censoring massive stories that could
change elections do you remember when
hunter biden's laptop story was leaking
and what did twitter do twitter actually
banned people not only from sharing the
story but you couldn't even privately
share the links to the new york post and
they locked the new york post out of
their account do you think that maybe
maybe that if more people had known
about hunter biden's laptop and hunter
biden's business dealings that clearly
were connected to joe biden hunter biden
was a crack addict who had no expertise
in energy who was getting all this money
per month from a ukrainian energy
company do you think that is sort of
relevant to what's going on in ukraine
now do you think that's sort of relevant
to joe biden becoming president but that
we couldn't talk about it then and then
of course my favorite
slow-motion conservative bill maher
even he gets these things right usually
two years late
the argument to me is like has twitter
failed
in setting themselves up in the past as
the judge of what can go out there and i
would say yes
you have you failed
when you threw the new york post off of
twitter
for talking about hunter biden's emails
and it turned out that was a real story
right you failed
when you said we couldn't read about
whether
covet had come from a lab
you failed
did you read about this babylon bead you
know what the babylon bee is
i didn't know this no it's like the
christian version of the onion
they got flagged
for
they posted a funny video this is funny
to them okay
sensitive content twitter said in the
video they were making fun of twitter
for being too sensitive this is so
through the looking glass
okay so you guys know and by the way i
know that if some of you uh are are
annoyed when i keep playing these bill
maher clips because you're like you kind
of want to smack me through the screen i
can feel it it's like dave he's never
going to fully get there he's never
going to fully get there but i'm going
to keep trying at least a little bit
more because i think that that slow
motion thing that he's doing needs to be
accelerated and i think maybe we can get
the rubber to meet the road with him
maybe we can maybe i'm completely wrong
but i think maybe we can and even if we
can't get him maybe we can get more of
his audience to realize what the truth
is right because hopefully if the
algorithms don't manipulate everything
there might be a person out there who
searches bill maher on the youtube and
comes across one of my videos and is
like oh this guy actually nailed what
what's been going on in the back of my
head when i watch real time why it's not
fully connecting what's interesting
there is bill maher finally is coming
around right he's coming on going they
did fail when it came to this new york
post story now it's interesting bill
maher didn't cover the new york post
story on his show when it was happening
now a whole bunch of us did and we were
called right wing maniacs for it we were
told we were going to be censored on
youtube and many of us were
but he didn't do it when it mattered
that's what i mean about slow motion
conservative then when it gets easy to
do something when the new york times is
like oh yo you're not going to believe
this guys but it's a year and a half
later and biden already president so uh
yeah you could talk about the laptop
then bill maher is like yeah why didn't
we talk about the laptop
okay so he says that uh he also to the
idea that you're going to say okay well
twitter
should have done something and not you
know basically should have not done
anything i should say they should have
not banned the new york post and
everything else it's like well you know
they probably shouldn't have banned the
president of the united states where
were you on that bill
yeah nowhere on that one too you did
call for a recession though to get rid
of trump uh so again this is like are
you getting this or not uh and then oh
and then the lab leak he mentions the
lab leak and it's like yeah bill where
were you on the lab leak for a year you
you were afraid to talk about it too for
a year i don't know if the lab leak is
true or not but at least we some of us
were asking these questions
so just come on bill
and i know the producers watch the show
i have my insiders i know you're
watching just get there bill i don't
even want to do the [ __ ] show i
really don't i don't i'm not even that
interested in talking to him anymore i'm
honestly not but just get there man get
there
send me a nice bottle of wine at the end
that would be about tequila would be
better actually but the point of all of
this
is that the election
was manipulated by big tech so it is not
disconnected when you see public people
having their accounts blown up jordan
peterson or me being suspended when you
just follow those dots backwards and you
go boy they were censoring other things
back then and gosh darn it did those
things have an effect on the election
and it's yes yes that they did so you
guys know i like to go back to some
things that happened in the past so we
don't forget right because we just
forget things that happened literally
two weeks ago uh but how about uh new
york post this is october 2020.
twitter backed down on its battle with
the post and unlocked its main account
after a two-week stalemate over the
hunter biden expose the move came after
the post refused twitter's demand that
it deletes six tweets that link to
stories that the company claimed without
any evidence were based on hacked
information the post never budged and
kept the tweets on the account during
the standoff even as twitter obscured
them from view in a series of tweets the
social media giants that it was revising
its hacked materials policy and updating
our practice of not retroactively
overturning prior enforcement our
policies are living documents said one
of the tweets from twitter safety we're
willing to update and adjust them when
we encounter new scenarios or receive
important feedback from the public the
company claimed the post violated a
policy on sharing hacked materials by
tweeting links to bombshell exclusives
on hunter's emails without ever saying
how it came to that conclusion and
despite the fact that neither hunter
biden nor anyone else had claimed that
the emails were hacked the move sparked
widespread outrage that led twitter to
revise its policies so other users could
tweet the stories but it continued to
hold the post's account hostage
demanding the six tweet tweets about its
own reporting be deleted they never were
while we've updated the policy we don't
change enforcement retroactively you
will still need to delete the tweets to
regain access to your account a twitter
representative told the post on october
16th twitter also made the six tweets at
issue invisible to users by replacing
them with messages saying the tweet is
no longer available okay
so look i know you guys know all this
and i know that this is two years ago
but i think you see what i'm doing right
i'm prosecuting a case here and they can
take out a whole bunch of people now and
what is it that we won't be able to say
in two years and the simple fact is the
twitter never censors anyone on the left
for any of their lies right do they ever
put any warnings on joe biden's tweets
when joe biden lies about literally
everything putin's price hike inflation
is transitory uh any of the stuff the
vaccines work i mean do they ever censor
any of that no they only censor people
right by the way they never censored new
the new york times when the new york
times showed donald trump's tax returns
illegally it is illegal to do that it
was a hacked document they had no
problem showing that and i'm fairly
certain guys what do you think about
this one if donald trump jr had had a
laptop and he was smoking crack with
prostitutes and like snort and blow off
their asses and a whole bunch of other
stuff do you think that uh that would
have been allowed on twitter um do you
think am i nuts
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure that would
have been allowed on twitter so it is
all [ __ ] people it is a fake game
and this gets me back to where i started
about i'm trying to figure out how i can
play in this game do you continue to
play in a game based in lies do you
continue to play in a game where you
know the rules are fixed and you don't
even know exactly what the rules are in
the first place or do you just walk away
not exactly sure i'm really not exactly
sure but i but i am enjoying reading
your thoughts on this uh interestingly
when that whole new york post thing
happened uh you guys know jack dorsey
from twitter he was the ceo at the time
here is what he said much later much
later of course straight blocking of
urls was wrong and we updated our policy
and enforcement to fix our goal is to
attempt to add context and now we have
capabilities to do that
um
okay whatever yeah again it's like slow
motion man when you had the ability to
do something you didn't do jack [ __ ]
jack you didn't do jack [ __ ] and now you
don't even run the place anymore by the
way he probably doesn't want me to say
this but here we go uh i dm'd jack
dorsey yesterday to alert him about my
suspension uh and i asked him to amplify
it and uh he
basically he was like oh i have nothing
to do with twitter anymore so then i
wrote okay could you at least get me in
touch with someone at twitter and then
he didn't respond
because it's all a fixed game and the
people who get us into all of these
messes are not truly our allies or
anything else
anyway uh
you may remember elon musk during all of
this uh subsequently he said this on
twitter which was pretty good
suspending the account the twitter
account of a major news organization for
publishing a truthful story was
obviously incredibly inappropriate okay
so that's pretty good right so that's
what he said a while back and as you
know he is in the process we believe of
buying twitter it's a little unknown
what's going on because he had these 10
days where he went silent on twitter
then he came back suddenly
two days ago and guess what he said this
is literally
uh from look at this 5 17 a.m on july
5th now i got banned about an hour and a
half before this
someone had asked him
uh
if they had if he had seen that jordan
peterson was banned he wrote yeah
they're going way too far in squashing
dissenting opinions okay so elon musk
you know that they took out jordan
peterson elon musk you have no
you undoubtedly know that they have
taken me out now are you buying this
thing are you going to fix this thing
are the hopes that we've pinned on you
either justly or unjustly
are they are they worthy are you going
to do the right thing i hope that you
will
um but i do know also that if you try to
do the right thing they are going to
come for you we we absolutely know that
there has been hit piece after hit piece
about you elon musk since you decided to
get in the twitter game since you
decided to say hey i'm going to defend
speech what did they start doing they
started calling you alt-right and a
racist and all that stuff
and of course they also went with their
double speak you may remember this one
this is from about a month ago
uh this is just i mean this is one of
the most incredible videos i've ever
seen this is from the televised mental
institution of msnbc they've got a host
that nobody watches the show his guy his
name is ari melber but the you know the
machine loves these people who just say
nothing lie about everything confuse
everything accuse you of doing what
they're doing et cetera et cetera listen
to what he said in case you missed it
when uh the whole elon getting twitter
thing was breaking you own all of
twitter or facebook or what have you you
don't have to explain yourself you don't
even have to be transparent you could
secretly ban
one party's candidate or all of its
candidates
all of its nominees or you could just
secretly turn down the reach of their
stuff and turn up the reach of something
else and the rest of us might not even
find out about it till after the
election
elon musk says this is all to help
people because he is just a free speech
philosophically clear open-minded helper
you see
they tell you what they're doing
that's what they did during the election
turn things down
turn other things up that's what they do
then a guy comes in and says more voices
less censorship
let's see what's really going on here
and they freak
out about it
so once again i want to reiterate what
jordan peterson said about ellen page
who was a woman her entire life who is
still biologically a woman
and i don't care about her i don't care
to make this about her but what jordan
peterson said about ellen page was a
hundred percent true and i cannot call
ellen page who was the actress in x-men
elliott page because that was a woman
named ellen page
now what's interesting is not just that
what jordan peterson said was true of
course it was what the new york post
said was also a hundred percent true and
they paid the price for it too uh and
now there's more leaking out to connect
this to what's happening actually right
now in the world there is far more
leaking out about hunter biden and the
fact that joe biden absolutely
did know that hunter biden was having
business dealings in china
here is a voicemail this is just
breaking in the last 24-48 hours a
voicemail of joe biden calling hunter to
talk about his business dealings with
china
hey palace dad it's 8 15. um
on wednesday nights the chance give me a
call nothing urgent
i just want to talk to you i thought the
article at least has been on online
that's going to be printed one time it
was good
and you can clear
and uh
anyway um
if you get a chance give me a call i
love you
okay so the article that he's referring
to is about
hunter biden's dealings with china okay
that's that's been
verified already we'll get to that in a
sec because even the press secretary is
addre is acknowledging that that is true
now this entire time and you remember
for
dealings also if he did have business
dealings it had nothing to do with joe
blah blah blah blah here's a whole bunch
of times that joe biden lied about
hunter biden's dealings
period i'm not going to i'm not going to
respond to that let's focus on the
problem focus on this man your son did
make a lot of money there some reports
50 to 80 000 a month in a ukrainian
company while you were vice president
i'm not look here's what i'm not gonna
do i'm not gonna and i know you're not
attending to this play the game to take
the eye off the culprit
there's nothing on his face that was
wrong
so look if you want to talk about
problems
you know let's talk about trump's family
i mean come on here's what i know
i know trump deserves to be investigated
and what i wanted to make a point about
my son's statement speaks for itself he
spoke about it today
my son's statement speaks for itself
what i think is important is we focus on
why it's so important to remove this man
from office
okay so he of course always was throwing
it back on trump and we should
investigate trump's kids for what for
what they're good parents and actual
functioning adults with jobs and
families and things of that nature
and of course he consistently is lying
there's nothing here that this never
happened
well now even our black lesbian press
secretary is admitting that yeah
something kind of did happen
why is there a voicemail of the
president
talking to his son about his overseas
business dealings if the president has
said he's never spoken to his son about
his overseas business
well first i'll say that uh
what the president said stands so
if he if that's what the president said
that that is what stands and second
secondly
but secondly
secondly business dealings and he says i
think you're clear
how is that not him talking to his son
about his overseas business feelings
we're not from this podium i am not
going to talk about alleged materials
from the laptop i will
i'm not
i am not going to talk about alleged
materials on the laptop oh it's not
happening then that it is not peter i
refer you to uh to his son's
representative
okay so what you need to understand
there is they're admitting it and i'm
telling you they are getting rid of joe
biden soon enough they are he obviously
is not running in 2024 even if it had
nothing to do with this just because of
the cognitive stuff but they are getting
rid of this guy soon enough they used
him as long as they needed him i don't
think they expected him to break down
this quickly i don't think that enough
of this would be that they thought that
so much of this would be exposed so
quickly but they're getting rid of him
she's sort of in on it too right because
she's kind of like yeah yeah there's
some stuff there but i'm not going to
really talk about it here they are going
to string him up and congrats to dr jill
biden you will have a special place in
hell for what you did to your husband
your basically incapacitated husband so
what do we do
what do we do well i have to make a
decision do i go back into the rat's
nest and and fight in a place that they
can constantly multiply and morph and no
one knows who your enemy is and how they
can take you out and all of those things
but at least you're in the game and
you're fighting or as i said earlier do
you abdicate the throne do you go hey
it's time to go i put a lot of effort
into twitter jordan's got i don't know
three million followers i've got like a
million and a half you have influence
there you have an ability to get
information out whether you like twitter
or not as i said earlier it is the the
pr service for the world but do you just
say hey you know what i am done with
that
the promised land is over there i'm
going there do you say egypt i've had
enough
do you go over there
i have to decide that i have to decide
and i really i'm listening to you guys
on this i'm talking to jordan about it
and ben and some others and i'll decide
what what i'm going to do on this oh and
i do want to mention
that i jumped on truth social in the
midst of all of this
as just another way to get message out
there and i have to say the engagement
has been incredibly good i am at dave
rubin if you want to follow on truth
social i have been super impressed i
have something like 70 000 followers
having never been on there it's probably
more than that now i don't it's not
about the numbers but the engagement and
i was looking at the comments and it's
like it's real people twitter has become
so bot-filled and obviously fake and all
of those things so so you've got options
the point is you've got options and
that's why we built locals that's why we
merge with rumble that's why truth
exists and and all of these things and
it doesn't mean that any of them are
perfect either but there's options at
least so what do you do
as you make these decisions in your life
what platforms will i be on how much
will i engage with the con the people
who are always lying because ultimately
the people who are always lying it's
like they've got all of this energy here
in their whirlwind of lies and the more
that i go in yeah maybe every now and
again i can pull someone out of the
whirlwind and and get them out but most
likely i'll just be sucked into the
cyclone and part of the destruction so
what do you do
you fight them and expose them on your
terms your terms that's the key to this
so here is the woman who i believe is
going to be the next governor of arizona
i've had her on the show carrie lake she
is a fantastic fighter of freedom
watch what she did to a cnn reporter a
couple days ago
hi harry hi hey nice to meet you
you don't have a mask on anymore
outside
wow well we're six feet apart do you
have a minute to chat um i'll do an
interview okay as long as it airs on cnn
plus
does it still exist i didn't think so
because the people don't like what you
guys are peddling which is propaganda
thank you
you go girl as they say i'm not a
biologist but you go girl yeah that's
perfect you you destroy them to their
faces
300 million dollars that is how much
money cnn put into cnn plus and it
failed within a month do you know how
much money we've put into advertising on
this show
zero
white supremacist zero dollars we've
done this all on
i don't know putting out decent content
working with good people busting our
butts trying to do something that's real
and honest and then hopefully you guys
share it and spread the word and come to
shows and buy books or whatever it might
be that's what we've done and no matter
how much money they pump into their
lives people know the lies i believe we
have something internal in us that that
knows what time it is and sometimes you
can get confused and sometimes they can
spin the clock so you really have no
idea but at the end of the day i believe
that the truth prevails so i'll figure
out what i'm going to do on the on the
personal side of this but i think you
have to figure out what you want to do
related to all of this and and how
you're going to go forward with all of
this that's what we all got to figure
out so let's jump to some comments from
the locals community where there are no
bots or trolls or or evil leftist
wackadoodle woke freaks schmidt says let
twitter cancel and censor themselves
into oblivion yeah
that's part of the argument part of the
argument i think would be that you'd get
a mass exodus that i would get everybody
i would do my best to wrangle every
influential person that i'm associated
with and and all of us say on in one
loud voice hey today is the day today is
the day we're leaving today is our
independence day we play the speech from
independence day the movie and then we
just all leave on one given day and
whether we all go to truth or whether we
all go to locals or whatever we do
we do something we all do it together
and then you let the thing crash and
burn that's probably what has to happen
the reason i have this little caveat at
the moment is because i still don't know
where elon is at with all of this it's
like again an hour and a half after i
was banned at 3 30 in the morning an
hour and a half after that
just after july 4th he's tweeting that
they shouldn't go after jordan peterson
well jordan peterson's still not on so i
want to give elon a chance right i want
to give elon a chance to get the reins
of this thing expose what the activists
have been doing what the employees have
been doing
and then fix it so there is some level
of leash there np says that mlk was able
to protest injustice without trashing
our entire system of government yes
that's why that clip is so beautiful
that we play it in the cold open because
he's saying hey if we just get to those
documents if we act as if what is
written on that paper is really true
and it is really true if these are the
documents that freed us that everyone is
created equal then maybe we're not
acting that way right now when he's
saying this in 1967 but maybe we can get
there and that's what the american
project has been all about and these
people don't want to leave well enough
alone which is why we're suddenly
unearthing all of this evil stuff he did
not want america to be different he
wanted america to be its best self and i
think
if if martin luther king had seen the
america of three years ago i think he
would have been pretty damn proud i
really do i think if you would have
taken it's year two of the trump
presidency i don't know whether he would
have liked trump or not like trump or
anything else but if you would have just
basically looked at america
and looked around and said boy
everyone's treated equally under the law
people can marry who they want to marry
there are no laws that are unjust
related to someone's immutable
characteristics sure we've got some
polarization okay this that the other
thing but like did we do the thing did
we do it to the best of our ability
did we ensure
that a young black man is not going to
be judged by the color of his skin but
by the content of his character in a
public sense are there going to be some
racists yeah but in a public sense did
we do all that he would have been pretty
damn proud i think he would be i think
he would be disgusted by what the modern
left and the modern democrat party has
become who use all of the things that he
fought against as a crudgeal over the
rest of us patrick says information
pollution is an orwellian phrase that is
extremely dangerous even when uttered by
a potato yes indeed it is and everyone
should read 1984 if you haven't read it
lately or you can go over to the prageru
channel where i did a book review with
michael knowles about a year ago on
1984. a reminder if you want to see me
live where they absolutely cannot censor
me you can get tickets to our show on
july 14th it'll be a live reuben report
at miami improv.com we've got a cold
clothes for you in just a second uh and
as i said more more than ever if you
just take a moment
to just subscribe to our rumble channel
it's rumble.com ruben report because who
knows how much longer i'll be on youtube
like i'm in the thick of it this is just
the reality right i'm in sarlacc's pit
right now but boba fett came out turned
out we found out 40 years later he got
two days of star wars references for me
back
it's been a while um and of course you
can join us at reubenreport.locals.com
we got a ton of new members yesterday
and i look forward to talking to you
guys and hearing your thoughts on these
things right like i have this
incredible
community of people who can share their
thoughts and not everyone i i posted
this thing this morning about should i
get back on twitter or not there were
dozens and dozens of comments all over
the map but thoughtful and interesting
get on fight stay off walk stay you know
like all of it it's all there and and
that's what maybe we can get back to but
i don't think we can get back to it if
uh if we're just playing these games
where we're being manipulated and
censored and the rest of it uh part two
of my interview with bill o'reilly is up
right now and we do get into his little
blowout at the airport when he was going
to turks and caicos and ended up calling
the flight attendant a scumbag hey
nobody's perfect uh that is up right now
the full thing's already up at locals
and finally we close
in case you're worried about everything
guys don't worry here's a little
inspiration from kamala harris
despite the odds and the obstacles
we push
to move forward
that we are guided by what we see
that can be
unburdened
by what has been